listening to them and join them and i
guess
um so the purpose of this discussion
would be to talk about exploration maybe
broaden the conversation a little bit
from maybe specific topics moving to
general ones i guess i was just noting
some some themes that were coming up
throughout the talks
that um we've had um so
one of those themes i think is how do we
evaluate progress so ian was talking
about
um b suites um
will mentioned kind of some of the
pitfalls of overfitting to rl
um chelsea's talking about maybe you
know
moving from the object level to metal
level rl exploration there and how that
maybe
maybe there's some less um or different
kinds of pathology with respect to
overfitting and
we're fooling ourselves on progress so i
think that's kind of like a really
interesting topic something i'm
interested in and i hope we can talk
about
um there's also um i think that i'm
really interesting as well that
about meta-learning exploration versus
designing ourselves and which which of
those things we think
um is promising for different situations
um and uh
will's talk i think uh hit a little bit
on the challenges of
eventually when exploration to kind of
work in this like hierarchical way where
you're exploring not only on just you
know taking actions but on tape with
good options and i think that's kind of
a
really important topic so those are kind
of some of the really the broad things
that i that i noticed
um and maybe i i guess what i'll do is
just maybe i'll see conversation here
with
one or two questions but i guess as i do
that i want the
speakers maybe to also be thinking of um
questions that they think
should be asked so i also want speakers
to to kind of think of the big questions
that
we as a field and exploration should be
thinking about and feel
to feel free to kind of pop those onto
the stack and we can kind of ask
ourselves those things um so maybe just
to begin with um to see discussion
um i think i just find myself drawn to
this question of evaluating progress
because i i think it can be kind of deep
and also
confusing sometimes to think about um so
how should we think about progress and
exploration in nrl
um is it um
you know benchmarks of the way so like
you know like in working on b suite is
that if we if we solve those those
benchmark problems if we're kind of
codifying the
the things we think are the ingredients
of progress is that the way we should go
or or
is there something deeper there like
just about in true insights and
exploration would they be revealed by
benchmarks for some of the way
so it's kind of a broad question but
it's happy to see where that goes and
any of the speakers can
can feel free to to chime in on that
so one day the point that i can give
against benchmarks is that when we
actually started
the main paper that i presented where we
were looking at exploration and meta-rl
um we looked at kind of the existing
things that people had evaluated on
in the meta reinforcement learning
community and none of them really
challenged the exploration aspect of the
problem
and when we then kind of took all the
algorithms that were developed on those
so-called benchmarks because they
weren't really introduced as benchmarks
they were just introduced as
evaluation in various papers uh when we
evaluated them on a problem that really
challenged exploration
they really fell flat and they they
couldn't find a good exploration
strategy
so um i think that it's hard to have the
foresight for what exactly
um what exactly will
what are the challenges what will
challenge our algorithms and so forth
um in general i'm i'm generally a fan of
benchmarks but i think that they need to
be really continuously evolving with the
field based off of
where our current algorithms are at so
that
we can continuously add kind of our
latest knowledge and insights into what
we know are
the challenges for current methods
yeah i mean i okay thank i guess so
there's a bit of a tragedy in the
comments here so i'll i'll jump in as
well
i mean i definitely think that um you
know it's um
i guess one thing to remember is that
the expiration i guess at least the way
that i think about it
and probably most people um is that it's
not this like magically separate thing
from the rest of our owl
um you know you can tell when you're
doing good exploration when you're doing
good rl
um i guess the problem is or it's not a
problem but i guess maybe
the the issue that a lot of us think
about is that you know being fully
even being fully greedy and like
dithering for expiration
can do quite well in certain domains
when paired with reward shaping
when paired with whatever domain
knowledge when paired with whatever
so that it can be kind of hard to to say
oh look
you know i guess that that expiration is
one of these things maybe it's one of
the last things that we seem to be hand
tuning you know in our agents i know
that's definitely true with alpha star
um you know the one thing that they
would always do by hand
is the perturbations to find the new
agents
and so um you know i think
for for me b sweet i guess the important
thing about that is to try and stake a
claim of like okay
if we can instantiate certain benchmarks
that will exist in some way
to represent some aspect of the
exploration problem
then these can be good representatives
that can add
like they can become part of the
ecosystem so that people realize oh wait
there's something here that needs to be
solved
um as opposed to just like oh well what
do you mean i'll just you know add a
shaping reward for that
so i think that maybe it's something we
need to discuss and what do we expect
from our rl
algorithms
i'd like to add something mainly that i
i really agree with a couple of
different points that
they've just made that our benchmarks
should be kind of evolving
over time and the
the thing that i would like to add to
that though is that
exploration and this is towards what ian
was saying but exploration is
so tied to all of these other parts
of rl right it's it's super tight to
representation learning
to credit assignment like if i devise
some amazing
exploratory policy but it's so far off
policy that my
on policy learning algorithm or or
policy gradient method
can't really make use of that that's not
a very useful
exploration method so exploration maybe
more than almost anything else is so
entwined in rl
it gets very hard to to evaluate i i
like the idea of having benchmarks that
we're continually
adding to and making sure that they're
kind of they kind of cover the
space of problems that everyone cares
about because it's really easy to focus
on the problems that i care about or
you know you focus on the problems you
care about but having
sets of problems that we we all think
are important
seems really useful
um i'll i'll give my
uh my viewpoint on this as well which is
you know i think uh one way to also
avoid
uh falling into the overfitting trap for
particular
um particular uh benchmarks for
particular
domains is to uh is to
is to make sure that we simultaneously
advance the the state of theoretical
understanding of
what we know about the methods we have
because i think
if we can have algorithms that have both
some kind of worst case guarantees as
well as uh
do something sensible in problems that
are easier than worst case i think that
can give us
a lot more confidence about those
methods than if we know only one or the
other
if i can jump in here joel is wrong i
feel like i i i have to say
something about exploration benchmarks
um i think
the the benchmarks also have a really
valuable role
at moving the thinking forward in the
community i am going to
throw you to the alliance just a little
bit here um i think
go explore is an example of this did
cause a lot of steer
in the reinforced learning community but
i think he was saying well here's a
problem you think is a hard problem for
an exploration perspective and here's
here's a solution which maybe you didn't
even think was a solution and this is
also exciting in some sense right
yeah yeah it's funny i guess yeah being
thrown into the alliance um
i guess i think the thing um about go
explore that i think is interesting
and maybe other panelists would think
this this theme is interesting is um
kind of questioning some of our
assumptions like the formalism itself um
like you know for example um there are
some situations where you have a
simulator you can just exploit that
simulator
um in any way that's actually fine i
mean so maybe that's that's one class of
rl that we care about and
you know the gloves are off there we can
do whatever we want of course there's
other situations where you you know want
to
play more by the the standard rules of
rl um but i think it's kind of an
interesting theme i don't know exactly
how it ties into
exploration more broadly but um you know
questioning the reward function where
does the reward function come from and
how does that
actually um get codified in some cases
it'll be wrong the word function could
be wrong there's some assumptions that
we've baked in that just really aren't
um true
um so i mean like riffing on that i
guess are there other places where
we should think about questioning the
the formalism overall with respect to
exploration the ways we can cheat ways
that we can not cheat
um yeah it's kind of another broad
question i'm curious what everyone would
think about that
andrew if i may uh defense um
yeah this is this is related to will's
points earlier that uh exploration is
tightly coupled with other aspects of
reinforcement learning
and and i think in many cases the
difficulty in evaluating exploration is
how to separate
these exploration from other challenges
because also while
i think working on offline rl or call
crm is so much cleaner easier
um and it raises a question um that at
the end of ian's talk that when we
talk about different natures of the
problem in exploration benchmark
how do we measure uh generalization for
example or
of course or underneath the temporal
credit assignment how can we quantify
these
dimensions and then use it to uh to
capture the difficulty of a problem and
then to
benchmark exploration this is something
that i think would be interesting to
think about
along the lines of what joel was um what
was asking
i have a lot of thoughts on this from
the perspective of the works that we do
in robotics
so i think that with any benchmark we
really like
ideally we want it to reflect kind of
real world problems
that we care about uh one example of
that is robotics but there are
of course a wide number of other
examples where reinforcement learning
could be applicable
um but specifically in the context of
robotics there's
lots of assumptions in which
reinforcement learning is either a bit
too strong or a bit too weak
uh in my opinion so um
like access to a reward function can be
actually quite challenging in robotics
because you can just
observe what your sensors are giving you
you often can't observe
more than that and it's harder to find a
reward function on top of that
sometimes you can get demonstrations
that make the reinforcement learning
problem considerably easier or examples
of states that are good and bad and that
may also make the exploration problem
considerably easier
and in practice we very rarely run
reinforcement learning
from scratch without any sort of
demonstrations or any kind of starting
point from there
and then beyond that uh in this isn't
really built into the reinforcement
learning formalism per se but
we often assume that we can just kind of
reset the environment and have this
really episodic setting
where we can just keep on trying and
again and again and again and in
robotics
it requires a human to be there
constantly for the entire process and
almost defeats the point of
reinforcement learning itself
if the human has to be a part of that
process um so there are i think are all
sorts of assumptions that
uh that we should be reconsidering when
we make benchmarks and trying to
try to develop benchmarks that are
reflective of robotics kinds of problems
but also
other real world problems
yeah i guess i think to i think
reminding
going back to what lehon asked i i think
you know benchmarks are great
and if we can you know if we can distill
you know i think that be sweet you know
i guess i presented about that
that's one type of benchmark that i
think hasn't got so much attention which
are these like simple
diagnostic you know they're almost like
um didacty they're
there to teach you something by this
like example but ultimately
that's like a much weaker form of
understanding like nobody teaches linear
regression by example
on like all this nice data set right i
mean maybe you do like
you've seen that plot where they have
the like oh this curvy one that curvy
one this
up and down to show you like how things
can go wrong but you know
i think if we if we go to a state where
you i'd like to aim for a deeper form of
understanding
than that and and you know especially if
you know i guess what i'm maybe i'm
looking for
you know i think we all agree that um we
know that epsom greedy or whatever
that that's not good or boltzmann
expiration it's not good enough right
we know it's not good enough from theory
and we know it's not good enough from
examples
and so let's let's develop the tools or
examples or experiments or maybe theory
that will help us
get something that works a lot better
and and that means algorithms that work
better in terms of data
and information gathering
anyone else want to chime in on this or
i can um
redirect
all right we have to farm for dissent we
have to farm for conflict on this i
think we are all too reasonable
all right all right i could i could i
could actively farm for descent i
suppose
um so here's like i don't know an
interesting question that i struggle
with thinking about sometimes i'm
really curious about um the panelists i
imagine that i kind of maybe understand
some sort of
position already but um you know there's
a question as we think about maybe
scaling rl outcomes to really really
really ambitious things you know
um so robotics policies can do like just
about could learn to do
everything a human could do or or
something like that um
and there's a question about like what
we should what should we hand design an
exploration and what should we which we
learned so you know
chelsea's been talking about metal
learning a lot of other people been
talking about kind of
you know hand coding exploration
strategies and i guess sometimes i don't
know how to think about um
yeah which is the more promising
approach or maybe neither is and they're
both good for different situations but
maybe there's some descent there we
could kind of
illuminate um should we do we should we
invest more in that learning should we
invest more in object level learning
what do you guys think
i mean as chelsea said like you still
got to be able to solve a single task in
order to do metal learning right so you
can't completely ignore
uh understanding exploration in a single
mdp
and designing better exploration
algorithms there uh
i think you know we we can't completely
forgo that but i think i do think that
yeah like
there are uh interesting
uh uh i mean definitely the more we can
learn the better i think the
uh you know the the thing that maybe
we have to also become
uh better at is a lot of the
exploration algorithms that we currently
design often
they're they're designed with like
particular worst case
scenarios or particular kind of problem
structures in mind and they tend to be
overly wedded to that those structures
and this was some of this was also
coming out in for instance
will's presentation and just having
um approaches that for instance when
they see something that
really is amenable to epsilon greedy
because there is such rich signal coming
in the problem every time step
well you better not have just as poor
behavior as you would have in like ian's
deep sea or something right and
having that uh ability to adapt quickly
i think is
um is still largely missing from a lot
of approaches
i think if we had those uh we could we
might actually feel much better about
the state of exploration
um in our l
yeah i guess i'll i'll say i agree with
with alec on that you know
i think you know and i guess it links to
an answer i gave to martha's question
but maybe someone else should also try
and answer that
deepsea is definitely something i think
it's an example that's informed
by some intuition from the tabular
setting and i think that the tabular
setting
is basically where by far the lion's
share of
exploration research has been done but i
i guess you know
alec you know you definitely you know a
lot of people in this group are are
pushing towards but but just because we
have that and just because i you know
i'm someone pushing hey let's have this
tabular winner
in as a sanity check i think that we
shouldn't lose track of
of the the focus which has to be
expiration with generalization
and so generalization you know okay
they're different words but you can say
generalization you can also talk about
exploration with prior knowledge you
know the interesting point of
exploration is not
the first action in your tabular raza
right you
you open up atari game and you take your
first action no algorithm can do
anything good on the first action right
that's not interesting
so the interesting is like you've played
it for a while you know some stuff
there's some other stuff you still don't
know there's generalization
which is you know similar to having
prior knowledge
which is similar to having the meta rl
settings so i think that's the
interesting
you know that's what we have to aim for
and what we need to focus on
i i super agree with what ian just said
and
and want to just say like this this kind
of gap between
completely separate tasks where meta rl
is is typically
applied and just applying the same type
of uh method of reusing experience and
generalizing to new problems in how you
explore
seems like the the way to go that there
is no like clear task
boundary that we're con we would like
our algorithms
to be constantly kind of meta-learning
the the type of things to consider from
an exploratory standpoint
even if it's in a single lifetime
yes one thing in general i agree with
everything that's been said i will say
that
i think that will said that maybe
there's no task boundary and i think
that
in general i think that's reasonable but
i also think that um
it allows us making that assumption
allows us to get more traction on the
problem
and there are situations where we can
build tasks and and build task
boundaries and that may allow us to
do considerably better on the problem
than if we assume than we were if we
were in kind of the most general setting
uh and given how hard the reinforcement
learning problem is i'm all for kind of
making
whatever assumptions we think are
reasonable in various problem domains
to to make things more tactical and and
more practical
um that said i agree that like in meta
rl like this defining the tasks is a
burden
uh in some ways you're kind of taking
the burden on like from like
i don't know reward design or something
like that and moving it towards the
burden of
designing these task distributions uh
and hopefully we can also
move away from defining the task
distributions at some point and and
place it in even easier place to
uh to specify like maybe we just have to
write down a bunch of sentences that
correspond to the task that we want our
thing to do
and that would be like that would be
great then it just like derives tasks
from that or something
um yeah i'm i think that we should
be constantly rethinking the problem
setting that we're in whether and the
assumptions that we can introduce to
make things easier
at least from the standpoint of making
progress on on real world problems
uh i'm gonna try to stir up more uh
controversy
we'll see if it works but so
my question is is exploration
in deep reinforcement learning sort of
inherently stuck
until we understand uncertainty in
neural networks
like it's this just is there not much we
can do
until we crack that problem
i think it's a depends on how you define
the exploration problem in reinforcement
learning if your goal is to define
deep reinforcement learning in deep
reinforcement yeah but even then like
there's
there's if your goal is to divide to
define a single
strategy and an algorithm for
exploration that works across a wide
range of
problem domains it may be possible that
that just doesn't exist
uh that it may be impossible to kind of
define an algorithm that
works as well as we would like it to on
all the problem domains that we care
about
um yeah yeah so i
i think the only hope sorry i had a food
delivery sorry i
didn't mute it but um um i think the
only hope is that you have to say you're
designing
expiration algorithms for the expiration
algorithm ideally is going to take in
some you're going to say i want to make
something that's good for any rl
algorithm
it's good for a certain family of
environments right and
then the expiration and whatever should
be tailored towards this and you know
i think meta rl makes this very explicit
or i guess like it's almost like
workmanlike and like what's the
distribution what's the distribution
you've seen
and you should learn from that like
that's very concrete but even if you you
know it's basically the same thing as
like the bayesian
prior or you don't even need to be
basing you just have to say hey
which environments do i care about and
which ones do i not and probably if you
say hey i don't care about deepsea or
whatever
well you can hope to do better and and
this has to be
what we're aiming for like of the right
exploration it's like you give me the
family and i give you good expiration
for that family
yeah so i mean i i think you know in
in some ways uh like
so it's sort of certainly a valid
one-way implication you could say right
that
if i had an amazing way of
characterizing
um uncertainty in
neural networks um you know that should
certainly be useful for exploration and
reinforcement learning
uh i do think that once we start making
structural assumptions about the
underlying reinforcement learning
problem we might be
it's it's uh plausibly uh
what we need for exploration can be
easier than a generic uncertainty
quantification
right so uh a pretty um
again um interesting example
of uh this that at least i've seen in
some theoretical work
work is
um so if you have these um
like block mdp style models which is
basically that there is an underlying
markovian tabular state but you instead
observe
a higher dimensional emission process
from it uh
then yes you can kind of do
um exploration then you can build things
using
neural networks still uh where you use
the neural networks
uh to basically perform like two sample
tests
uh by noise contrastive estimation uh
but
but what what comes out of that is a is
a valid um
kind of uncertainty quantification for
the purpose of exploration at least
uh so while it's not a completely
generic
uncertainty characterization it it sort
of works it's a it's a valid one within
that model
and i think uh that's the sort of uh
pattern we're probably gonna
uh see repeating uh over and over again
more generally
in in reinforcement learning problems or
we should i mean i'm i'm sort of
again like you know this point's been
made a few times before but uh
we really should not hesitate in
leveraging problem structure as long as
the structure is coming
from uh representatives of real
applications
we just should should be careful not to
overfit to like the structure present in
atari or majorco
i like alexander and actually want to
take it further and say
since since we need to be controversial
here i think actually trying to
characterize uncertainty in your
networks is actually probably
what is keeping us stuck uh i think
there's a lot of environments where
you get exploration for free and maybe
as we scale up
our techniques i mean exploration will
remain a problem but it might be
easier in the places where right now
we're looking um
a good analogy here is maybe backgammon
right if you're famously back him and it
was
uh was a domain where we could make
progress as our you know nrl
because it mixes very well right uh i
suppose riding a bicycle i don't know if
that's a good example or not but
certainly
you quickly learn if you fail at doing
the thing correctly what happens
um i i would guess you know
there's all kinds of things that we are
uncertain about in the real world that
we somehow are
okay not exploring and
whether it's a structural assumption or
simply that there's another drive
that causes us to behave differently uh
i'd love to explore some of these ideas
myself personally and i guess yeah i
agree that's a good point mark and i
want to point out something you know
having mentioned
deep sea or these pathological whatever
you know
okay well i definitely noticed the
similarity between
maybe you know oh you need to worry
about this type of efficient deep
exploration
and the same type of people maybe who in
the 90s were like hey
you can never optimize a neural network
by gradient descent because it's
non-convex and blah blah
okay um so make you know it's possible
i actually don't think i'm not quite
ready to
to give it but i'm i think there are
parallels there and you should be
worried about that you think if you work
on expiration and you're worried about
like all these things you should be
worried
hey is this something that actually
matters in real problems maybe just
being greedy and a bit of dithering
is okay and you don't need to do
uncertainty qualification
i think that you know i think i think
the room
the great success of uncertainty
quantification in deep rl
has not come yet
so that should make us worried ian do
you think that's
due to some you know potential
limitation of uncertainty quantification
or is it maybe that like daniel was
saying like we just haven't cracked that
particular
problem well enough i think it's more
like that you know i think
actually people give all these memes
like oh
deep learning has been around since the
80s they had it all figured out
but it turns out well okay look there's
obviously more to it than this but
i think if you have to say it values
instead of sigmoids
quite important um adam instead of sgd
or like different momentum things quite
important and mostly if you had this big
sigmoid network and you did sgd with
constant step size
it basically doesn't work and so and now
everyone's like oh it worked the whole
time
it didn't really work man but yeah the
main ideas were basically there and i'm
hoping that it's something like that
that that's kind of what i'm hoping is
that we need the sort of relu
or the atom that kind of unlocks the
epistemic uncertainty and because we
know it can be important in
simple things and i guess in my bones i
feel like it's
even more important in important things
but i will admit the evidence is not
there so you should be suspicious i
think
so we are kind of hitting the the
official
time i do have allowance to go up to 15
minutes over
so i am tempted to use that because i
really enjoy this discussion but i
don't uh maybe what i'll say is is for
um for panelists like sorry for speakers
they can stick around please do stick
around
for audience who wants to stick around
please stick around and i think there's
also kind of a link floating around
now to the um yeah they gather uh if you
want to kind of jump to the social
um but um
maybe i kind of want to open it up to
kind of questions that we should be
asking that we're not so maybe like for
the speakers or anyone who has this sort
of idea like
what are some of the some of the big
things that we should be talking about
maybe they're underappreciated
that are issues within um exploration in
dbrl
i need to go to a ta meeting soon but
i'll very quickly jump in on this
and say that uh i feel like i'd love to
see more work
on thinking about exploration when you
have a little bit more than just a
reward function
when you have examples of good states
when you have demonstrations
something along those lines i think
there's been a little bit of work on
this but
it's really not the kind of mainstream
reinforcement learning research
and it's it is a situation where it's
pretty practical in a pretty large
number of domains
um i was going to add not necessarily
related to what chelsea just said but um
you know i think there's a real issue
with
i like benchmarks by the way but uh
there's a real issue with
benchmarks become like benchmarks
maximization becoming
kind of the you know measurement of
progress
and um one of the ways that this can be
done is by
varying you know you other parts of your
your training paradigm
in ways that like maybe don't make
things exactly comparable you know i can
i can adjust my neural network i can
adjust
how i'm training and all these ways that
aren't necessarily doing a
real even comparison and and part of the
the excuse for that is because it is
really hard to
to do a really apples apples comparison
if my
setup is slightly different than your
setup um
but i think this is really problematic
because we can go down all sorts of kind
of blind alleys or
or or make mistakes about what we think
is actually happening i don't have a
solution
because i do think benchmarks are really
useful but i think this is
this is something to worry about as well
yeah when you say that will um is it is
it speaking to the challenge of
reviewing
and that um that oftentimes
reviewers will use just benchmarks as
sort of like a first heuristic whether
something's worth looking at
and it's like just that there's pressure
than to hack that heuristic or is it
um is it also something deeper about
just the challenge of
understanding whether something is
insightful or not on a deeper level
um yeah i think more on the the second
side i
i don't think i can i can blame
reviewers here at all i mean i think
we are the the people doing it um
but like a really easy example which is
like something i can call out on my own
work is like
comparing you know if if i do something
with a huge number of
environmental frames and compare against
something with very few
there's just no reasonable way of
talking about what's going on between
these two
algorithms and benchmark
maximization really kind of encourages
that and many other ways of kind of
getting your your your method to look
look solid
or or even diluting yourself into
thinking that it's solid
that i think that problem though is um
you know i think that
i completely agree will but i think that
that problem
you know let's just i want to highlight
another benefit of like what b suite is
but the benchmark
you know we can have the benchmark which
is do x in
a certain amount of frames right and
that can be the focus
but you know i think that there is
there's an uneasy tension
in rl in general about like oh
well what are we really trying to do
like are we are we
doing atari because we want to get a
really good atari
player right alphago is the big success
of rl
but the truth is what they really wanted
was a really good policy for playing
go right nothing else mattered okay and
then the same is kind of true of a lot
of the dqn or whatever that's the focus
like
i want a really good policy that comes
out at the end and then there's i think
the expiration stuff really
you know if it was to be successful it's
all about hey i want an algorithm
that's going to be ongoing in the world
and it's going to learn really well and
all these things blah blah blah
and i don't like set off i don't like
turn epsilon to zero for
you know this final game or something
like that right
um because i'm doing these games because
they're a make-believe for
this unknown future where like rl will
rise to the fore and it will do all this
ai stuff for me right
but it's not um even within demand you
know i think we have this tension
you know is the ai the policy or is it
the rl algorithm
i mean that's a that's a nice segue to
the other thing i wanted to point out is
when we are
you know of course like both in both in
theory and these domains when we study
exploration
uh because we still by and large
uh kind of um
ignore this complexity that well really
the spirit of exploration as the agent
is going to be just like
be out there and be interacting with its
real environment and
suffering the consequences we don't
really see
that much work at the intersection of
exploration with other concerns like
safety and robustness and
you know maintaining sort of a viable
performance uh
level so that you know somebody doesn't
pull the plug on your algorithm
uh in a real system and
how do you in some sense uh make
reinforce make exploration interoperate
with all those complexities i think is
i mean it's really hard but it's really
important if we want to
get these real agents to be tried out in
important domains
yeah i think i have a resonate with uh
you know well
like the comments that uh from will ian
and attic
is uh i mean perhaps in a slightly
different form
is for for off policy rl that we
discussed yesterday
i think the sort of you know the real
world applications are a little bit more
clear whenever you have
a lot of like offline data historical
data and you want to do better
making sequential decision making this
is kind of like the application like
target for uh you know offline rl
whereas for
online exploration uh i think the
situation is less clear and
i think that partly has led to the
confusion we currently have is like
uh it's because you know you when you
say i'm gonna do
exploration like in an environment like
before you
you talk to the people in that for that
domain
you kind of don't know like what kind of
exploration you're allowed to do like
alex said like safety constraints and
all of that and
you know it's uh it's a bit unclear and
also
as well i think it's well said you know
what kind of additional feedback
uh and probably chelsea uh additional
feedback and signals do you have
to to make your exploration potentially
like much much
uh easier uh so maybe we need to i don't
know
just work on that direction a little
more to
uh to guide us in terms of like what are
more important than exploration
i mean in some sense that's partly why
i've also found it interesting to think
more about reward free exploration
lately where you really are kind of
being forced to ask yourself what are
the other signals beyond just the
explicit reward that you
should or could leverage um i do think
that
i mean most of that still ends up being
largely pretty homogeneous in terms of
okay maybe i'll just like try to
do some prediction problem about my
future uh but sort of the more
certainly the more heterogeneous data
sources we can leverage
better it is
all right well maybe i will um close out
this session i
really appreciate alec ian well uh
chelsea and
absentia um for this really interesting
discussion it was a pleasure and
um yeah i think the social is going on
right now and i hope to see some of you
there
thanks
see everyone on uh tomorrow i really
love all the talks and discussion
and a big thank you to all the speakers
for the fabulous talks and
joe for moderating the inspiring
discussions uh come join us tomorrow
when we talk about optimization and rl
and deborah thanks for joining us right
now to social as well
thanks thank you
i